[Music]
we've got a bank 211 in progress
suspects are armed and they have taken
hostages all units stand down you
watching
yep how are you gonna get out of this
[Music]
you know this is GT correct dealing with
different animal hair boys
right now Los Angeles branch of the
Federal Reserve Bank has never been
robbed that's why we're gonna Rob it
gangbangers these are not the National
Bank Hollywood job Laguna Niguel you
know these guys we solve all these cases
this is the crew it's been visit do we
look like the types will arrest you we
just shoot
addicted to heists sooner or later I
need to fix the Federal Reserve billions
of dollars are taken out of circulation
if we can break in and steal those old
bills before they're destroyed we got
our hands on money and it's untraceable
acacia the joint from the inside the
gone baked hey you know just means and I
am a member of a gang of the we have
badges you're not the bad guys we are
Friday make sure he knows it's all I'm
gonna let you know now better wear your
best buy Mo's you should understand
advise suspects wearing body armor head
shots only my signal let's go
thank I've enough it's okay I bring my
cuffs anyway
[Music]
you